so when i got out of prison i had now
just a short while
and some days when i saw ronald reagan
blue eyes on the television
saying that the communist sending easter
government was in the cocaine business
and my guts turned to ice water i said
oh barry has done it
so then it was later on that afternoon i
got a call from him
he said i'm coming out tonight roger
i'll meet you at this little um
french restaurant town i don't even know
what was there so i'll be there at nine
o'clock where was this
in for santa barbara okay so um
i came in the door at seven at nine
o'clock and he was laying at the back of
the
thing and he'd gain weight and he was
leaning back
and i walked up to him i said are you
wired barry and he said no
i'm not i said well i'm not gonna say
anything just tell me
so he just started talking and i looked
around and i says
uh de agents he said every one of them
there's about 20 people in the room blue
jeans ladies with leather skirts and all
alone and
so the room was full of dea agents and
i'm
i'm on this hot seat so
he started telling me and he just said
roger they they wrapped me up and
they um left me holding the bag
i couldn't do anything but testify i
couldn't do three life sentence
and he put his hands up over his eyes
and the tears ran down between his cheek
between his fingers he's i just couldn't
do it i just couldn't do it
he said so i've gone to congress [ __ ] he
said i went to see edwin meis
i was attorney general at the time i
flew my jet up there and i knocked on
the door and told him that they was
bringing
tons of cocaine out of colombia and he
wouldn't believe me kicked me out and
the next day i went back i said i can
prove to you
that they're doing it so give the guy
jake jacobson
he put him with him he was a dea agent
and
we went down and did one and a half tons
and
i bullied the plane in at nicaragua took
a thousand pictures
and i testified before congress and i've
told them all year apart
but you're under my umbrella as long as
you testify with me
exactly what i say and use my lawyer
you can have your passport have your
money you can live anywhere in the world
you want to
i said barry they're going to kill you
friend oh no ochoa brothers this another
he's in spain another one dead and this
and that another
and uh so i
so the the dea agent came over and he
sat down we had
chevis regal and ice and we had a nice
time i liked him he's a i think a crop
duster from alabama
would have been on the same team i'd
have been all right i really did like
the man
yeah and he just said listen you can you
can come to miami tomorrow in change
or you can come first class with mari it
doesn't matter to me
but you're going to testify before a
federal grand jury
and if you do you can keep your money
your passport you live anywhere in the
world you want to live
but if you don't the only place you're
going to ever see your family again is
in a federal
prison visiting room and he said and you
got to have your
pilot from santa barbara you got to give
him up
barry knew that i was flying had another
airline going
same as him did more than he did but he
didn't know who columbians told him i
didn't ever tell him
right right they trying to give a little
competition i think
so i went to the festival restaurant
that night
it was on my birthday january 26 1985.
and barry knew that was i like that
restaurant
lovely restaurant no name on the door in
miami
yeah and carl gables so
i went in and uh him and his wife came
in
debbie she was looking real pretty and
very was and we had dessert
together and i just told him barry i
just
just can't do it i said they gonna kill
you friend
he said oh no i hugged his neck
who were you telling him was going to
kill him the columbia's going to kill
them surely certainly they're going to
kill him of course they're going to kill
him i mean
if he testifies against all you're just
going to die man you ain't got no choice
right i mean you can go now but you
these guys are ruthless
doesn't matter where you are they'll
find you right it's almost anybody you
tell like that
most of these people kill you you're
destroying their lives and their
families and
children and all that sort of stuff and
you did it and you did it with your
eyes wide open and you made a deal you
just
you just can't tell so most people don't
live by that honor and so a lot of them
get killed
and uh so anyway i hugged his neck
i may have kissed him and anyhow mari
and i and the children fled to brazil
and the next day or what well yeah right
away
i think went back to the house and got
some things and we were gone
now what is it what's the story with
with how bush was involved with barry
i don't know anything about that barry
has two pictures
of george and uh uh jib
bush walking away from his plane in
opelocka airport
where they just bought two kilos of
cocaine that's all what he said
that's what barry said and they got a
package
and she snapped their picture as they
going away from the plane
so i don't know and i think that's been
on the internet some too
is it possible that the um i mean isn't
it true that the
american government or the cia or the d
whoever it was the dea
made it extremely easy for the
colombians to kill him and to find him
to barry yeah i don't know i don't think
so i think that
yeah well i tell you i don't know who
did it but uh
do you do you think that they wanted him
dead do you think the u.s government
wanted him to have the dea and
not particularly i think i think that
the police in louisiana wanted him dead
the dea in that area
right where they've been chasing me just
say you guys ain't got sense enough to
catch me
or i'm not doing anything today going to
be burning that government gas up
you know he just bait him a little bit
yeah they wanted to go and take his
picture make sure he was dead
but i don't think he did anything to
make people really hate him that bad
but anyway he was flaunting it in front
of him right
and uh and the judge is the one now who
who influenced the judge the judge
killed him because he has already
testified against all these colombians
and the judge gives him six months
uh in a halfway house every night at six
o'clock he's got to come in
so the judge said him so that's his
death sentence that yes 100
and he's attached to that [ __ ]
halfway house and they're definitely
going to find him there he got to go
every night at six o'clock
and the dea stood up in court and said
your honor this is a death sentence
they will kill him he said he should
have thought of that before he did this
wow and he said well you're going to
have bodyguards no
a guy in prisoner can't have bodyguards
he can have
arms he can't have nothing he got to
drive right up into that
halfway house every night at six o'clock
and he was waiting on him just riddled
him
you see the pictures on the internet he
just they said he put his hands over his
ears
he shot him like 50 times in that car in
the car when he came
oh my god it was sad how did you feel
where were you what were you doing do
you remember what
the moment when they came to tell you oh
we got a great news barry
mario in colombia and that's when he
told me oh
great news great news they killed barry
seal you know well i cried
i went to omari and miriam they cried he
was our friend
even though he had he testified he put
me in there
he did the best he could they the cia
had left him holding the back
100 they set him up and whenever all
that oliver north stuff
come about arms for cocaine and an
iran contra deal they just they just
split
everything was in his name everything he
was a one what's he going to do
his own people see he was a cia man did
you know that
barry was with the cia prior to all this
prior to the airlines right and he had
over a thousand parachute jumps and he
was george bush's
real good friend the old man he was his
protege
and when he died george bush's personal
phone number was in his wallet
and the lawyer called and he said hey
barry how you doing nobody and they said
they just killed barry last night and it
clicked and he hung right up and right
up yeah
jesus christ man
wow what a [ __ ] story i'm glad to be
out i
thought one time i'd never get out of
prison
so you're in when you got the phone call
about barry where were you in brazil
yeah i was in brazil and uh so we're
living in brazil and
um i got word i was up in somewhere in
brazil and i was calling to colombian
they owed me a bunch of money maybe
three and a half million dollars
so i was trying to collect some of that
and as long as barry was alive and this
thing was going they was going to pay me
but when barry died
oh have good news good news they killed
barry seal last night
or yesterday or sometime and i cried and
i told murray and my daughter cried so
anyway how long after this how long
after you moved to columbia did they
tell you this
six months six months after you missed
yeah i'm sorry after you went to brazil
i think that it was january of 26th of
1985
that i was would barry yes at the
restaurant
yeah and then i think he was killed july
of 86 just there about
about six months later he was killed wow
so now they have no case against me